قال رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه
عبد الحميد دبيبه ان حكومته ترفض المراحل
الانتقاليه والحكومات الموازيه وان
الانتخابات وفق قوانين انتخابيه عادله هي
الوسيله الوحيده لاستقرار ليبيا من جانبه
رحب مبعوث الامم المتحده الى ليبيا
بالقوانين الانتخابيه التي قدمتها لجنه 6
+ 6 لكنه اضاف انها غيرك كافيه لقياده
ليبيا نحو الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات والرسائل التي حرصت
دبيبه على توجيهها في اجتماع حكومته وكيف
نفهم رفضه الحديث عن حكومه الانتقاليه
جديده وتمسكه باجراء انتخابات وفق ما سماه
قانونا انتخابات عادل وما خلفيات تحذير
المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا من وجود حكومتين
في البلاد وما سر تشكيكه في مخرجات لجنه 6
+ 6 التي تدعمها الامم المتحده بشان خطتها
لاجراء الانتخابات وما هو افق حلول الازمه
السياسيه في ليبيا بالنظر الى المواقف
المتباينه للاطراف السياسيه والعسكريه
الليبيه وما سبلوا التوافق على اجراء
الانتخابات في موعدها
[موسيقى]
خلال اجتماع عقدته حكومته في حكومته في
مدينه غامس غربيه ليبيا شن رئيس حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه عبد الحميد دبيبه
هجوم النادعا على من سماهم من يحاولون
العبث باختراع مناورات لافشال الانتخابات
مجددا رفضه القاطعه لاي مرحله انتقاليه
جديده في البلاد تصريحات الدبيبه التي
جاءت بعد نحو اسبوع من تاكيد رئيس مجلس
النواب عجيله صالح
ضروره تشكيل حكومه موحده تشرف على اجراءات
الانتخابات المنتظره شددت ايضا على اهميه
ان تكون القوانين الانتخابيه عادله وغير
مفصله على احد بعينه
يحتم على الجميع
مسؤولياته وترك الفرصه للمبادرات التي
تضمن وجود قوانين عادله ونزيهه وقابله
للتنفيذ غير مفصله على لطرف او لطرف اخر
او منع طرف اخر او تمكين طرف اخر كاس اساس
التشريع والعدل فان غاب العدل عم الظلم
وضاع الحق
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى امنيه يوركا
الدكتور عبد الحميد صيام الخبير في شؤون
الامم المتحده ومن اسطنبول نزار كريكيش
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
الليبي سيد كريش ابدا منك واذا اردت
فلنبدا من من المكان الذي كانت فيه
تصريحات دبيبه لماذا اختار
اقدامس مثلا ولم يكن ما قاله من طرابلس
هذا كان جاء في سياق دعوه
لحضور واجتماع يعني في مدينه اقدامس نعرف
ان المنطقه الجبل الغربي كان فيها بعض
التوترات فبالتالي رئيس الحكومه يريد ان
يجري هذا الاجتماعات في اجواء يعني في
الجبل الغربي خاصه لانه يعني يبسط سيطرته
على هذا المكان فبالتالي هو يريد ان يظهر
بانه موجود في المنطقه الغربيه ليس في
طرابلس فقط وانما في كل المنطقه الغربيه
وهذا ما يقوم به الان يعني يحاول ان يبسط
سيطرته ويحاول ان يمتد لان المنطقه
الغربيه شهدت بعض التوترات خاصه بعد قرار
وزير الداخليه
بتفكيك بعض المديريات الامن في الجبل
الغربي لكن الان الامر استقرت واصبح فيه
حاله من الاستقرار فهو يعني يتقرب او
يحاول ان يقترب من هذه البلديات هذا الفعل
يعني داب عليه لرئيس الحكومه في التعامل
بلديات في الشرق والغرب والجنوب وقد كسب
هذه البلديات واستطاعت بالفعل ان يمد يده
اليها رغم وجود عقبات سياسيه من انقسام
السياسي لكن هو يمتد او يعني يساعد هذه
البلديات كورقه او كمقربه يعمل بها منذ
بدايه حكومته فهذا ليس بجديد ولكن ياتي
الان في سياق بانه هو موجود في المنطقه
الغربيه ككل سواء في الجبل الغربي سواء في
الزاويه بعد ان حدثت اضطرابات سواء في
المناطق الامازيغ كبعد عن حادثه بعد
اضطرابات والان في اقدامس هو موجود
فبالتالي هو يعني يقول بان هذه الحكومه
تبسط تبسط جناحها على يعني اغلب المناطق
في ليبيا دكتور عبد الحميد الى اي مدى هذا
مهم كما اشار السيد يعني ليس الامر جديد
ولكن ياتي في سياق يود دبيبه ان يقول له
من ان سيطرته لقد ليست فقط في اماكن معينه
ويريد ان يقول انه يبسط سيطرته على الغرب
ايضا في هذه الحاله
شكرا جزيلا حقيقه حكومه عبد الحميد
الدبيبات افتخر بانها في السنتين
الماضيتين كانت الامور افضل من سوابقها في
ليبيا يعني هناك شبه استقرار
طبعا مناوشات هنا خاصه في مناطق الغرب
ولكن بشكل عام اذا ما قارنا السنتين
الماضيتين مع بقيه السنوات الاخرى ستجد
انه يفتخر بانه اعاد نوعا من الاستقرار
لليبيا لانه هو خارج المنظومه السياسيه
ولذلك له علاقات مع الجميع وقام بزيارات
لكافه انحاء ليبيا وهو مدعوم دوليا ويقوم
بزيارات متواصله وقاد حضر مؤتمر الغذاء
والامن في ايطاليا مؤخرا
وعاده شركه الطيران الايطالي لتهبط في
مطار طرابلس فلديه الكثير ما يقوله وهناك
طبعا جهات اخرى لا تريد لليبيا ان تخرج من
مازقها ما زالت تصر على ايجاد مرحله
انتقاليه وراء مرحله انتقاليه ما زالوا
يبحثون عن قضيه الاطار الانتخابي وهل يجوز
للعسكر ان يرشحوا انفسهم ام لا وهل يجوز
من يحمل الجنسيه الاجنبيه ان يكون مرشحا
وما زالت هذه الامور تحت ضغوطات محليه
واقليميه حقيقه تعكس نفسها في الخلافات
داخل ليبيا هو قال في اجتماع وكان اجتماع
و الاجتماع ساعود الى ساعود الى ما قال له
ولكن دعني اسال السيد عن ذات النقطه مر
رسائل التي اراد ان يوصلها ولمن من خلال
حديثه في هذا الاجتماع الحكومي في
الان خلينا في ثلاثه اطراف اساسيه في
ليبيا في طرف مجلس النواب والى حد مائي
يتبعه يعني مجلس الاعلى للدوله خاصه
الاطراف التي تريد ان تسيطر على السلطه
التشريعيه لتصميم النظام السياسي وفقا
لمصالحها هناك طرف خليفه حفتر وهناك طرف
الاتفاق جنيف بما يسعه عبد الحميد بيبه او
يتضمن فيه عبد الحميد الدبيبه هذا الطرف
يسر على اتفاق جنيف بانه الاتفاق الذي وقع
بمعرفه الامم المتحده فبالتالي هو اتفاق
مستمر وهذا الاتفاق يقضي بان لا يكون هناك
تغيير في اتفاق جنيف الا بعد صدور قوانين
انتخابات والماده الاولى من الانتفاخ جنيف
واضحه بانه هو تجرى انتخابات برلمانيه
ورئاسيه متزامنه وفقا لقوانين انتخابيه
يعدها مجلس النواب ومجلس الاعلى للدوله
بالتوافق وفق خلفيه اتفاق الصخيرات
فبالتالي هو مازال يصر على هذا الامر
دبيبه يقول يعني لن اترك الحكم الان لن
ارضى بحكومه موازيه لن ارضى بقوانين تفصل
على بعض الاطراف كما ذكر يعني لو كانت هذه
القوانين فقط هي معده لخليفه حفتر او
معدلي استبدال عبد الحميد الدبيبه او
لمنعه من الانتخابات كل هذه الاشياء هو
رفضها في هذه الكلمه هو يقول انا ساذهب
بعث الامميه انا جئت ضمن اتفاق جنيف غير
هذا لن يكون هناك خروج فبالتالي ما حدث في
بوزنيقه لاتفاق سته زائد سته كان يتحدث عن
حكومه جديده هو يرفض كذلك هذه الحكومه
الجديده فبالتالي هو يصر على هذا المسار
اللي هو بداوا من ذو البدايه انه لن يترك
هذا الحكم الا بانتخابات حره ونزيهه وتاتي
شرعيه جديده وهذا طبعا سيعطل المسارات
الموازيه ككافه فبالتالي حتى موقف بتيلي
تاتي في هذا الاطار اريد بعض القوانين
التي
يمكن ان يقنع بها تاتي الى كلام ايضا لكن
دكتور عبد الحميد
ما رايك يعني الرجل متوسط متمسك بمسار
معين
ولا يبدي اي مرونه فيما يتعلق باي مسارات
اخرى موازيه يعتبر انها
تسعى كما قال تفصيل القوانين لشخصيات
معينه
نعم هو يمثل حكومه وحده وطنيه وصلت الى
هذا الموقع بالاتفاق اتفاق جميع الاطراف
تم التصويت عليها وقيل ان هذه الحكومه
ستستمر الى ان يكون هناك اطار انتخابي
وتتوجه الدوله نحو الانتخابات ما زالت
هناك عقبات في الوصول الى مرحله
الانتخابات الغيت انتخابات ديسمبر 2021
بسبب التدخلات وبسبب عدم التوافق على
الاطار الانتخابي ولذلك هو يرى انه يمثل
الشرعيه يمثل كل ليبيا هناك توافق على
قيادته من الخارج ومن الداخل علاقته مميزه
مع كافه كثير من القوى خاصه الدول
الاوروبيه وتركيا وكذلك الامم المتحده
ولذلك هو يرى ان ازاحه هذه الحكومه التي
اوصلت البلاد الى نوع من الاستقرار سيدخل
البلاد مره اخرى في الفوضى وعوده مراكز
القوى للتاثير الامور وعلى الانتخابات
لذلك هو يرى ان الضمان ليبيا للوصول الى
حاله استقرار كما قال هو في كلمته في جده
مصر ان العدل والاستقرار هو الذي سيخرج
ليبيا من ماء اتخاذ قرارات عادله
والاستمرار في حاله الاستقرار الحالي الذي
وصلت اليه البلاد بعد سنتين من حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه دعنا لسنا على ما قاله
المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا عبد الله باتيلي
وقد رحب في حديث ادلى به للجزيره
بالقوانين الانتخابيه التي قدمتها لجنه
سته زائد سته لكنه اضاف انها غير كافيه
لقياده ليبيا نحو الانتخابات وانها تحتاج
الى تعديلات بحسب قوله باتيلي اشار ايضا
الى ضروره مشاركه كل الاطراف الليبيه في
العمليه السياسيه من اجل التوصل لاتفاق
شامل
البعد القانوني للانتخابات ليس كافيا
والبعد السياسي مهم للغايه فالازمه ما
تزال قائمه منذ 12 عاما وقبل عامين من
الان تم تشكيل حكومه جديده اما الان
فلدينا حكومتان في ليبيا ومن المهم جدا ان
نحل هذه المشكله اذا يجب ان تشارك كل
الاطراف في العمليه السياسيه للتوصل الى
اتفاق شامل بين مختلف الفرقاء السياسيين
وليس فقط بين المجلس الاعلى للدوله ومجلس
النواب يجب ان يكون هناك اطار قانوني
مقبول من غالبيه الاطراف
دكتور عبد الحميد ما الذي يمكن ان نفهمه
من كلام عبد الله بهتيني
نفهم بان اي اتفاق بين خالد المشتري
وعقيله صالح سيدخل البلاد في ازمه جديده
باستبعاد حكومه الوحده الوطنيه هناك اطراف
موجوده على الساحه ويجب التشاور معها كذلك
هو يقول بانه ايضا خلال جهوده قدم ملاحظات
كثيره لجميع الاطراف حول موضوع الاطار
الانتخابي وضع ملاحظاته بعد ان التقى
بكافه اطياف الشعب الليبي يعني منذ ان
تسلم هذا المنصب الى الان وهو يلتقي
بالاطراف الليبيه وضع ملاحظاته للجنه سته
زائد زائد سته التي التقت مؤخرا في المغرب
للتوافق على الاطار الانتخابي لكن بعد
ملاحظاته لم يؤخذ بها ول هو يخشى يخشى انه
اذا اتفق مجلس النواب مع المجلس الاعلى
والثار في طريق ايجاد حكومه حكومه اي نوع
من الحكومه بالتالي ستخلق مشاكل جديده
ليبيا في غنى عنها المفروض يجب الحوار ان
يتم الحوار والتواصل بين جميع الاطراف
للتواصل الى اتفاق مرضي للجميع والتوصل
الى اطار انتخابي يقبل به الجميع والا اذا
فرض فرضا فلن يكون هناك حل في ازمه ليبيا
هذا الموقف من باتيلي سوف يكون
يعني مرضيا بالنسبه للسيد دبيبه في رايك
وربما مزعجا
للسيده عقيله صالح ومن يمثله
والسيد خالد المشري
نعم وبكل تاكيد هو رفض يعني مخرجات سته
زائد سته لكن بطريقه دبلوماسيه يعني بمعنى
سيطرت مجلس النواب والمجلس الاعلى للدوله
على السلطه التشريعيه لن يتيح له ان يرسم
المسار السياسي كافه فبالتالي البعد
القانوني هنا لا يكفي يعني السلاح الذي
يملكه مجلس الدوله ومجلس النواب هو اصدار
القوانين لكن هذه اصدار القوانين هذا لن
يكفي بالنسبه لعبد الله بتيلي فبالتالي هو
يسقط هذه الورقه من ايديهم او هذا السلاح
من ايديهم فبالتالي يريد عمليه سياسيه
كالتي قدمها لمجلس الامن فهو بالتالي
ينتصر لرؤيته هي التي ترى بوجود مشاركه
كافيه من القوى السياسيه لايجاد حل سياسي
فاظن ان هذا التصريح رغم انه اليوم زار
عقيله صالح وخرج منه على اساس ان عقيله
صالح حيعدل في قوانين سته زائد سته وهذا
قد يكون بدايه جديده لمحاوله من بديل
ارضاء
ما هو نوع التعديلات المطلوب
هو الان واضح من تصريحات
بتيل بانه يرفض حكومه ثانيه هي الاشكال
الان في قضيتين اساسيتين القضيه الاولى هي
قضيه
سعه
قدره هذه القوانين على
استيعاب جميع الاطراف السياسيه في العمليه
الانتخابيه واحد اثنين اصرار عقيله صالح
وخالد المشري على حكومه الثانيه يبدو ان
بتيل هذا الامر مرفوض تماما عنده ويريد ان
لهذه الحكومات ان تكون هذه القوانين ان
تكون اكثر مرونه هل يستطيع الان ان يبدا
يلعب في لعبه العصا والجزره مع جيلا صالح
وخالد المشري لانه قبل ايام صرح بوضوح بان
هذه القوانين لن تجدي وكان خرج بعض النواب
وطالبوا باخراج عبد الله بتيلي وبانه غير
مرغوب فيك مبعوث اممي اليوم يذهب هو الى
عقيله صالح ويتحدث عن بعض التعديلات في
مخرجات سته زائد سته فاذا هو واضح انه هو
يصر على المسار الذي اتخذه لنفسه بان
البعد القانوني لن يكفي مجرد قوانين مجلس
النواب مجلس الدوله ليسوا هم الاطراف
السياسيون الوحيدون الذين يحركون المشهد
في ليبيا وهذا واضح لكل ذي عينين لانهم
اصدروا قوانين عشرات القوانين لم يابى بها
احد حتى في مؤسسات الدوله نفسها بل ان
خليفه حفتر
يغير فيه غير فتح بشاغه
بغياب عقيله صالح والذي خرج وقال انا غير
راضي على ما فعله مجلس النواب غير راضي
يعني على خليفه حفتر فبالتالي الكل يعرف
بان ليس لهؤلاء هذين الجسمين سلطه حقيقيه
على الارض فالحل هو مشاركه سياسيه واسعه
للاطراف التي تملك القوه على الارض بما في
ذلك عقيله صالح وخالد المشتري بحجم القوه
التي يملكونها وليس بقوه التشريع الذي
يمثلنا دكتور عبد الحميد صيام ملا اوراق
الموجوده لدى باتيلي لتذهب الامور في
المسار الذي يريده
لن تدعم اي عمليه قد تؤدي الى ازمه جديده
في ليبيا
بديل الان يفهم الوضع في ليبيا جيدا يعني
اتصل بكافه الاطراف وبكافه القوى
الاقليميه وهو الان يفهم التركيبه الليبيه
تماما بان اذا هناك توافق بين القوى
السياسيه قبل ان يكون هناك تشريعات تصدر
من مجلس النواب او غيره لن يكون هناك حل
اذا الورقه الدوليه وهي مهمه جدا الشرعيه
الدوليه التي منحت لحكومه الوحده الوطنيه
الحاليه ومن قبلها حكومه الوفاق الوطني
وكان هناك قوه كثيره تحاول ان تسقط حكومه
الوفاق الوطني لكن الدعم الامم المتحده
واعطاء الشرعيه للسراج كما هي تعطي
الشرعيه الان لعبد الحميد هي هذه الورقه
المهمه التي تملكها الامم المتحده واذا
خرج بتيل وقال هذه الحكومه التي يشكلها
مجلس النواب والمجلس الاعلى يعني ستزيد من
الانقسامات الداخليه
تزيد من حده النزاع الداخلي اذا لم تقف
الامم المتحده وانت تعرف ان هناك قوه
كثيره مثل اعضاء مجلس الامن من دول مهمه
تدعم المسار السياسي والمسار التي تمثله
الام المتحده تحاول ان توصل الاطراف
جميعها لذلك هو قدم اقتراحاته للافراد
قدر
تي لي طول
هذه اشترك بين كل الليبيين ووضعه بين
ايديهم وكان يتمنى على الاطراف ان ياخذوا
بهذه الاقتراحات التي تجمع ولا تفرق لكن
هناك من
يصر على ايجاد مرحله انتقاليه جديده
وحكومه جديده وهو وهؤلاء ايضا هناك دعم
خارجي لهم وبالتالي قد تؤدي الى مزيد من
التفاقم الازمه الليبيه
تعتقد يعني بما لديه من اوراق صيد بتيلي
قادر على ان يدفع الامور بالاتجاه الذي
يريده وكما قلت هو مصر عليه
اظن ان البتلي لن يستطيع ان يفعل شيئا لكن
فشل مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله في التوافق
فيما بينهما هو الذي سيعطي لبتيل القوه
زخم الحركه لانه هو اعطى لهذا المجد هذين
الماجستين سته اشهر مهله في بعد تصريحاته
في مجلس الامن قبل حوالي ثمانيه اشهر
بانهم يعطيهم فرصه للتوافق ولكن في كل
مرحله يختلف هؤلاء الجسمين هذين الجسمين
فبالتالي هو الان يجد الفرصه مواتيه ويجد
انه هو بامكانه ان يدفع الجميع نحو خطته
البديله التي عرضها في مجلس الامن يبدو ان
عبد الحميد بيبه على التوافق مع عبد الله
بتيلي رئيس المجلس الرئاسي على توافق مع
عبد الله البتيلي لكن الان يريد ان ياتي
بمعادله ضمنها صعبه ان يوافق بين قرارات
مجلس النواب مجلس الاعلى للدوله وبين
مخططه الذي وضعه في مجلس الامن فهو يبالغ
في في في
تقدير قوته على الاقناع لانه بصراحه يعني
يبدو انه غير مقنع لكثير من الاطراف وغير
فاعل من المبعوثين اللي جاءوا لليبيا صحيح
هو يفهم المشهد الليبي لكن هناك
عدم الفاعليه التي لن تجعله قادر على
تغيير
هل بالفعل هو غير فاعل وان كانت هناك قوه
لن تاتي منه ولكن هو قد ياخذ قوه من من
انقسام
البرلمان ومجلس الدوله
يعني انا لا اتفق يعني دائما هناك اطراف
ليبيه تضع اللوم على المبعوث الخاص للامين
العام في ليبيا يعني هذا هو رقم تسعه من
المبعوثين الخاص كان منهم من بين
المبعوثين العرب وكان من بينهم قصه اللوم
ولكن هي قصه هل هل لديه القوه الكافيه حتى
يعني يفعل ما يريد
لا اعتقد ذلك هو يمثل قوه قانونيه دوليه
وشرعيه دوليه ويمثل ايضا قوه اخلاقيه كذلك
لكن اذا الاطراف الليبيه نفسها لا تتفق من
فيما بينها وهذا حدث في الماضي مرات ومرات
اذا لا يوجد قوه حتى لا
يتحد ان تفرض ذلك بالقوه هي تحاول هي تجمع
الاطراف هي تحاور الجميع تتوصل الى
توافقات بينهم وتطرح عليهم يعني عندما
عرضت الامم المتحده في في الماضي في شهر
سته 2020 قضيه وقف اطلاق النار وكذلك كان
هناك التوافق ليبيا حولها وخمسه زائد خمسه
هناك توافق الامم المتحده تطرح تقدم
المبادرات لكنها لا تجبر لا تستطيع ان
تجبر اذا كان هناك قوه محليه مدعومه من
قوه خارجيه وهذه القوه الخارجيه احيانا
تملك قوه الفيتو على ما يجري داخل ليبيا
بتزويد بالسلاح او ارسال مرتزقه الى اخره
فكيف للامم المتحده ان تفرض يعني ماذا اذا
لذلك تقترح تقدم ولكنها لا تستطيع ان تفرض
ماذا يمكن ان يكون المخرج ماذا يمكن ان
تكون القواسم المشتركه بين الليبيين التي
تشكل مخرجا للازمه وافقا للحل اظن يعني في
رايي وتفكيري بان المخرج سيكون اقليمي
وليس دولي وليس محلي بمعنى التغيرات
الاقليميه هي التي ستجبر الاطراف على
تغيير وعيها بالمشهد فبالتالي اذا كان حدث
اي توافق الان تركي مصري جزائري حول
تكونت حاله من الضغط الحقيقي من الاقليم
مدعومه بالقوه الدوليه بمعنى ان تكون
المبادره اقليميه وليست دوليه وليست حتى
محليه اظن ان هذا تكرر في في في بعض الدول
الافريقيه وبعض ازماتها مثل النيجر الان
وظن هو قد يكون فاعل في ليبيا لان لا احد
ينكر تاثير مصر وتركيا في ليبيا بل قوه
مصر وتركيا في ليبيا قوه حقيقيه على الارض
وهذا قد يجبر الاطراف الليبيه على ايجاد
حل وان تعيا بان هي غير فاعله فعلا لان
هناك الان نبرع الحديث عن ليبي ليبي وعن
السياده الوطنيه لكنها هي منتهكه منذ عام
2011 فبالتالي الان اذا كان الاقليم تتحرك
حركه عقلانيه لايصاء ايجاد حل بين هذه
الاطراف الليبيه والتقت من مصالح التركيه
المصريه لايجاد حل في ليبيا مع الضغط من
الاتحاد الافريقي ودعم من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والقوه الغربيه
لدعم هذا الاقليم ان يكون اكثر استقرارا
لانه هو ياتي في في قلب المعادله الدوليه
اظن ان هذا يكون متغير حقيقي في ليبيا
دكتور عبد الحميد تتفق الحل الاقليمي نعم
الى
نعم حل اقليمي مدعوم المجلس الامن طبعا
لكن معروف ان هناك تدخلات اقليميه معروف
ان هناك قوه
مرتبطه في الخارج وتنفذ اجندات في الخارج
فاذا كان هناك توافق اقليمي وهو الان يبدو
ان هناك توافقا اقليميا او قريبا من
التوافق الاقليمي اقتراب مصر مع مع تركيا
وكذلك الدوري الايجابي الذي تلعبه الجزائر
وتونس يعني من مصلحه البلدين ان يكون هناك
استقرار في ليبيا لذلك هناك الان تقريبا
ظروف افضل من وهناك حتى قضيه
مشغولون في مكان اخر وخروجهم من ليبيا بدا
يعني او عددهم اقل بكثير الان وتاثيرهم
اقل لذلك شكرا
شكرا جزيلا دكتور عبد الحميد الصيام
الخبير في الشؤون الامم المتحده من
نيويوركم من اسطنبول نزار كريكش الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي الليبي
الى هنا ناتي الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]